I've been asked to make a video about
the importance of a resource like Khan
Academy for a country like for a country
like India and before we talk about the
Indian specific context I want to talk a
little bit about what exactly Khan
Academy is because different people have
different perceptions of what it's about
so it did get it did start off and this
story is now kind of commonplace it did
start off with me making a bunch of
videos on YouTube and the video library
still is is a good fraction of what
students use then it's been kind of
crazy it's on the order of seven or
eight million unique students a month
are now using the videos and the rest of
the platform but we have the videos and
then we also have the interactive
exercises so I don't know maybe I'll
draw a man running to show exercises
although they're not physical exercises
well how good of a drawing that is but
we have the exercises we have the
exercises and it's all on a platform
where we're trying to capture as much
data we're trying to put game mechanics
we're trying to understand how we can
motivate and engage people in more and
more ways so that's all in a platform
I'll call it data analytics and game
mechanics well maybe I'll separate them
out so there's the data there's the data
part of it and then there's the game
plot part of it and when people you know
sometimes when you use some a word like
game mechanics some people saying oh
game mechanics that's you know that's
for video games that's not for serious
education but it's important to realize
that things like game mechanics are
everywhere it's just they're not
typically called game mechanics any
incentive mechanism really is a game
mechanic and frankly the ones that are
done in video games they're much more
sophisticated at incenting proper
behavior and you see that when you see
kids that are otherwise disengaged in
school they're highly engaged on complex
tasks often in a video game and to give
an example of it grades are game
mechanics credentials are game mechanics
even interviews our game mechanics
anything that there's an incentive
structure in place for students to do
something that is some form of a game
mechanic and we think that these things
these things can all be optimized
especially when you start using data now
given that we're doing all of this stuff
and we're trying to expand this as much
as we can so right now so in terms of in
terms of breath Khan Academy is mainly I
would call it kk
a ok for kindergarten k through
sometimes you hear K through 12 but I'll
say K through 14 which would mean k
through 12 and maybe your first two
years of college that's where a lot of
our content is and it's primarily
science science technology math and
engineering math I'll say engineering
and math typically called stem
engineering and math but there is a
little bit of other stuff in there there
is a good bit of economics economics and
finance and finance and even a few
there's some humanities including
including art history that's not done
that's not done by myself so this is the
breadth of things but we're hoping to
expand this more and more and really
push the envelope of what can be done in
terms of the content so over the next
several years expect to see one these
parts get richer but also see content on
grammar and vocabulary and we really
want to do explore how you can do even
open anythings things like writing and
you're even on the engineering side
things like computer science so expect
to see all of that from from the Khan
Academy now that on a way let's think
about the Indian specific context and
obviously there's India and there's a
lot of countries that are like India and
it's a modernizing country and needs
kind of a 21st century workforce but it
has severe problems I would say with
inequality and access to to a decent
education and so especially when you
think of india and the broadest sense
when you think of not just the urban the
the upper class in the urban you think
of the whole population of india there's
a bunch of problems the first one is
obviously just resources so access you
have resources so that's step one you
want to if right now you want to educate
a student you at least need the
resources to maybe build a school and
let's put khan academy decide let's not
talk about the physical realm let's
think about the virtual realm let's talk
let's put the virtual aside let's think
about the physical problems right now so
you need the resources to build a school
and hire teachers even if you have the
resources then you start facing the
second problem you start pacing the
second problem of finding the talent you
it might be easier at the primary levels
but if you want to teach kids in rural
India some
the more advanced trigonometry calculus
physics chemistry the people who who
know that might have already left the
village there might not even be be
available there so it's finding finding
the talent and I'm not saying that
they're not there they're definitely
cases there are but based on my
understanding it can be very difficult
in many rural parts of not just india in
the world to find the talent to be
really really strong teachers especially
on more advanced topics and then even if
you have the talent even if you have the
talent or something or fairly good
teachers there's the issue of teacher
absenteeism where you don't have where
you don't have good ways good
organizational ways to to control what
is happening in in you know in these
facilities that you might have in in
places that are far away from cities and
whatever else so my understanding is
things like teacher absenteeism
absenteeism I don't know if I'm spelling
it right absenteeism is a big problem in
India and then even if you're able to
solve all of these three problems then
you have the problems of actually
getting the students to show up so then
you have then you have I will just call
that student attendance student
attendance because obviously in some of
the less affluent parts of India
students have responsibilities to help
their family they might not have been in
school for some time there might not
even be parent support in circumstances
they might say hey why you why do you
have to go study algebra you're just
going to you know work on our family
farm for the next generation so there
might even be resistance for students to
attend and even if you get all of these
out of the way then you still have the
problem then you still have the problem
of you have really different levels
different skill levels and they're not
necessarily correlating with age so in a
traditional school all the 10 year olds
are in fifth grade all the 11 year olds
or in sixth grade or in all right I
guess in india we call it 6th class or
5th class i believe but but now if
you're in an environment especially in a
more rural environment some students
that at 10 or 11 might be quite literate
might be a kind of at their grade level
4 for mathematics well stuff might not
have been at school for forever and you
might have 17 or 18 year olds who have
trouble with basic reading basic
arithmetic not to speak of things like
algebra
so you have different skill levels
different different skill levels so we
think the real opportunity with
something like Khan Academy of virtual
resources if you don't have any of these
it provides a kind of a really good
foundation a really good basis for
students so obviously on the resource
side Khan Academy itself to deliver Khan
Academy to the incremental student is
free assuming they have access to
technology assuming they have access to
technology and that's a big assumption
that's a big assumption even in a place
like the United States much less a place
like India the good thing about
technology is it's getting dramatically
cheaper year by year there's news of you
know there's that word of that tablet
India a thirty dollar tablet you can
imagine a thirty dollar tablet even if
it's a tablet per student if it lasts
three four years now you're talking
about under ten dollars if I'm talking
about US dollars under ten dollars a
year per student so it becomes something
that approaching quite affordable and
then you would have to think about how
do you get access to bandwidth and
things like that but that also is
getting dramatically cheaper and
especially you know we don't see a
reality where kids would have to be on
their computer day and night you could
have one computer one tablet shared by
four or five kids and then the per year
cost per student becomes becomes quite
cheap so this right here is a problem of
adoption right now especially in a place
like India but we think that this is
going to independent of us is going to
be solved over the next decade
technology and bandwidth is going to
become dramatically cheaper and things
like cell phones they're getting more
and more powerful they have pretty good
penetration in in the developing world
and we think those the cell phones of
the future are going to be at least as
powerful as the computers that we're
using today and then on the talented
thing what Khan Academy does is it can
augment whatever talent is is available
locally so now through the videos
through the exercises the students will
have access to a broader pool of what do
you want calm lectures exercises and we
also want to create and I forgot to
write this down we also want to create a
sense of community on the site so
they'll have access to other learners
who are outside of their direct sphere
you know its physical sphere so I think
this could be a really powerful thing
absenteeism once again you know it's an
issue in the physical realm but in this
in the
virtual realm if a student has access to
a device of some kind then you actually
solve this especially if they have some
type of network connectivity because we
have the data we have the data and we
can we can essentially track in real
time if the asset is being used if the
kid is using his tablet how he or she is
progressing how they might be
progressing relative to a peer group and
see what what variables in their
environment can be changed or optimized
so the student gets more engaged or has
a better chance of success so we think
that a technology based solution can do
a lot for this problem student
attendance once again if a student has
to work during the day help their family
during the day or maybe part of the year
the beauty of virtual learning is that
it is at the students time so it is on
demand when the student needs it so even
if the student does have some
responsibilities for the family they now
have access to it maybe at night and
I'll even add this it's not just a
student it can change what's happening
in the family because even the adults in
the family will now have access to build
up their foundations without having to
be embarrassed without having to go to a
primary school and and and admitting
what what they may or may not know and
then and then the the kind of the the
biggest thing here is addressing the
different skill set and this isn't a
problem that's unique to a place like
India this is universal you go to even
the most affluent parts of the world you
go into a classroom every student is
being moved together the at the same
pace despite the fact that students are
all at different levels different people
take different amounts of time to learn
something and they tend to learn it in
different ways and so that's where I
think the real power of on-demand
self-paced mastery-based learning really
hits it so I think it's really
especially powerful there and then on
top of all of this we think that there's
a a kind of a meta-level international
thing here where a student in India can
connect with students across borders
they can start to connect with students
in Pakistan through Khan Academy maybe
eventually we don't have this
functionality they can be each other's
tutors they can communicate with kids in
the US and Europe and China and you
start to have kind of a global global
connectedness and it'll be a way for
students also we're hoping to and this
is something we're already working on
we're already doing translations into
Hindi Bengali and even Tamil we wanted
translate this into the major languages
of the world so people can access it in
their native tongue eventually the
videos are being done first eventually
all of this will be but it also is an
opportunity for students to get
proficient in things that have high
economic value like becoming a little
bit better in English so that you can
enter into kind of a more global
workforce so anyway hopefully I'm not
boring you this is a lotta this is
longer than my standard video but I
actually think in a place like India
that the potential for chronic head of
you might even be larger than it than in
the developed world